so helen your first competitive race
back
for five years and you win
another goal congratulations on that
what was that like
thank you yeah i was really nervous
actually at the start of the race i
think that
no matter what you've done before and
it's been so long since you raced before
everything
feels a little unfamiliar so just
getting that first race down was really
important
and so gold in london uh gold in rio
when did you decide for goodness sake
that you're going to try to take toki
probably not even a year ago um honestly
it was
i kind of had really come to a strong
decision by the end of the summer i
think i spent the summer
training and thinking about whether it
would be possible so yeah probably not
even a year ago
and what was it that made you decide
you've got three kids two of them twins
um what made you decide i'm gonna have a
go when did you was there a moment
in lockdown where you thought i'm gonna
give it a go it was a really
like slowly but surely process i started
to see my school's coming back
and at the same time i think i realized
it actually looked down and the
the pandemic was going to last a lot
longer than i originally thought so i
thought we're going to be at home a lot
longer
um i'm going to be spending more time on
the row machine could this be an
opportunity could this be a way to make
it work
and rather letting it work against me
actually it worked for me because i
could manage all my family time
around training and so yeah it's kind of
worked that way
and how has it worked out the training i
mean how are you juggling
a very young son twins and
training well a lot of it's done at nap
time so i'm as soon as they go down for
a nap i'm straight on the road machine
and generally weights if i'm doing
weights at home
the kids join in or i'm reading stories
between sets and it looks
entirely different to the setup that i
had pre london and pre-rio
but um i always think if i'm if i'm the
best mom i can be first that allows me
to be the best rower i can be
and i think definitely taking that onto
the water when i do get to go and train
on the water as well i think that i just
managed to kind of compartmentalize the
parts of my life
but rowers always seem to get up at dawn
you know like five o'clock in the
morning but then so do
young kids so how are you how are you
managing that
well i wake up with the kids first and i
have i actually have a couple of hours
with them in the morning through the
early hours and that's really really
nice and then i get to
to leave the house a little bit later
than i used to so a lot of my training
schedule is just done around them it's
not around them and their schedule and
um
i'm really grateful that polly my my
growing partner has just been
totally flexible about letting that
happen i gather you've been
breastfeeding
while you're training well not while
you're training obviously but i mean in
between
training sessions yeah and unless
especially when i first came back to
training and
leaving the house for the first time
that was a big thing i was kind of you
know trying to get back in time for
feeds and things like that but
um i'm quite a disorganized person by
nature so suddenly i had to really ramp
up my organization just to make sure
everything was running smoothly
and i saw in a i think it was a diary
that you did
this quote and you said i was looking at
my little girl and thought in 20 years
when you're making your decisions about
your life what can i physically show you
about who you can be and the chances you
can take
i found that very moving oh thank you
and i do see it as a chance you know
there's no guarantees that i'm going to
that i'm going to make it in this
journey there's no guarantees i'm going
to make the team but i really think the
bravest step is trying
and i would love to think that even if
she's 14 months old now even if she
doesn't remember it she'll know she was
there and she'll know the story
and i'd love to think that gave her a
boost or this kind of underlying
sense of possibility and it started out
yeah it started out largely for my
children and particularly for my
daughter but
the the surge of amazing amazing not
only well wishes but messages of people
saying that
this story has inspired them to try
something or go back and do something
they once loved before and haven't done
for years and
um that has really hit me in a way that
i never
i never imagined before when training
for london and rios
felt like such a personal journey and a
personal goal this feels like
there's um a huge community of people
who've
kind of taken this story and really
helped it change their lives and it just
that just motivates me more than
anything
well it's a wonderful story and is there
a sense too that you're doing it for
other mums
yeah definitely definitely i think that
mums can be so supportive of each other
and that's just incredible the first
person or one of the first people that i
phoned
when i was thinking about coming back
was anna watkins she won
gold in london and attempted to come
back after having children
and although she didn't quite make the
olympic team she's the one that you know
has all the advice for me
and if i don't make the team i want to
be the person that someone can call
and you know offer advice to them and i
think that supporting each other is one
of the best things we can do
and when will you know if you've made
the team how does all that happen
well i think over the next few weeks
there may be the final kind of decisions
the final rounds of testing so
i'm just trying to keep myself really
fit and healthy so if ever i'm tested
over the next few weeks i can show you
what i can do
and then i think i guess over the next
month i think those final decisions will
be made so it's
a little bit stressful at training at
the moment so in a way i suppose the
delay of the olympics
um sort of played into your hands a bit
yeah if the olympics hadn't been delayed
i would be watching from my sofa there's
no there's no possible way at time scale
so it's
yeah it's totally changed everything for
me this year i just wanted to make sure
that this year i came at the end of it
having i don't know having achieved
something having done something i never
thought possible
so i mean come on dare to dream what
would a what would a third
olympic goal mean to you i mean i i
genuinely handle heart don't really
think about the gold at the moment
because
i'm i'm thinking about selection i'm
thinking about making it there this time
last year i was i was not even a rower
let alone thinking about the olympics so
that's that's a little bit beyond my
thinking at the moment
yeah and i mean the next few months
you're just gonna carry on training and
put in the hard yards i guess
yeah we have a hundred days to go and i
think that the one thing i don't want to
lose sight of is the fact that from the
beginning i said
um i want to be the best mum i can be
and i'll fit the rowing around that
and i actually think that's made me the
best rower i can be because if i feel
like i've done a good job at home and a
good job as a mum
i i go to training just fully excited to
be there and knowing that um
that i've got the balance right yeah
well that's a great thought to end on
thank you very much for being with us
appreciate your time and uh look the
best of luck
and good luck with the kids as well
thanks